alors plus que quelques jours et ce sera
la fin du festival nuits d'afrique la
32e édition une édition qui a commencé
le 10 juillet et qui va finir donc le 22
sans dresser nécessairement le bilan de
l'activité on va quand même déjà tiré
quelques leçons en compagnie de la
directrice du festival suzanne rousseau
bonjour suzanne bonjour c'est un bon nul
à fric annoncé près de 700 artistes
provenant de 30 pays des antilles
l'amérique latine d'afrique évidemment
125 ans elle est ce que finalement tout
ce qui était promis a pu se réaliser
jusqu'à présent ça c'est une bonne
question c'est pas toujours vivant et
beaucoup de logistique autour du grand
défi que c'est tout le monde avec le
visant a atteint alors mais tu mens
travail de préparation derrière par une
équipe vraiment dévoués alors au niveau
justement quand vous êtes allusion aux
artistes qui doivent unique d'avoir des
visas est ce que cette année vous avez
quand même eu le maximum de personnes
que vous souhaitiez avoir des artistes
les artistes que vous avez invité des
accents venus de l'étranger
oui oui oui tout oui tout ce qu'on a pu
éviter cette année festival et chimie
mois on y va au jour le jour
journée chargée
voilà est-ce que cette édition 2010 8
s'est démarqué de façon d'une façon ou
d'une autre des précédentes a une
particularité les bons noms c'est comme
une nouvelle naissance
mais pour nous c'est un nouveau défi le
festival va faire beaucoup de
découvertes
donc on espère tout autant que les gens
soient curieux parce que oui il ya des
gens qui sont connues mais le côté du
coup de tête importants pour moi il ya
beaucoup de talent la musique évolue
énormément les gens évoluent ce qu'on
est content c'est depuis quelques années
le festival
de plus en plus multi générationnel j'ai
entendu j'étais avec quelqu'un de
quelqu'un de los angeles qui disaient
que leur public musiques du monde
vieillit c'est il n'y avait pas la
relève et moi ce que ce que j'étais
contente de m'apercevoir qui ont réussi
à rester pertinent pour aussi les plus
jeunes qui de plus en plus s'intéresse à
ces musiques lakhdar grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
donc c'est la propre hymne ils
n'attendent pas que les radios le jour à
la radio ils vont les chercher eux mêmes
donc grâce à tout ça les laines le
public s'élargit donc l'année passée on
avait fait un sondage de provenance et
d'achalandage vu que c'est vraiment de
25,75 qu'on arrive à aller chercher et
c'est quand même pas beaucoup de
festivals qui réussit à être aussi multi
générationnelle et bien sûr aussi
multiculturelle c'est vraiment une
richesse pour nous c'est ce qui fait
notre passion de réussir à rassembler
toutes ces cultures pas seulement sur 5
mai dans le public c'est vraiment c'est
tout ça que je voudrais brutale à ce
festival très important parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de de bien être physique fait
du billet mais de d'apprendre à se
connaître et dont on sent de plus en
plus que chaque année les festivaliers
attendent que les festivals commencent
et sont prêts à recevoir
et si ce que j'ai senti dès les
premières journées au pas par les
festivaliers que les artistes qui
montent sur scène qu'ils sont heureux
d'être accueilli par un public aussi
mélanger ou qui aussi prêt à recevoir
c'est vraiment ce que je pourrais vous
dire de cette édition la date
vous avez fait allusion à la dimension
découverte qui sont très importantes
bon parfois aussi il ya des grands noms
qui arrive cette année c'était femi kuti
parfois il ya le groupe kassav
bon sékouba bambino voilà c'est ça cette
32e qui n'est pas n'importe qui qui est
exactement mais parfois j'entends des
gens qui disent bay a peut-être passé de
gros noms et la question je vous pose c
est une question de budget des
disponibilités ou du groupe de
philosophie qui est axé sur la
découverte des plaines c'est son cas une
question de budget ce qui est
particulier pour nous si je remarque un
gros mot si on prend l exemple estime de
jazz qu'un grand mais qu'il ya plein de
festivals de jazz à travers tout le
canada
donc s'il ya des artistes qui qui tourne
c'est grâce à toutes les festivals de
jazz à travers le canada craint groupe
vient ils sont forts le partager avec
d'autres défis de nuit d'après c'est de
créer son propre réseau et de partager
ces instants avec d'autres festivals
dans d'autres villes du canada et des
états unis
alors c'est le grand travail qu'on fait
à l'année longue pour un artiste de
venir pour une saga
c'est difficile parce que si tu prends
un artiste qui vient une semaine c'est
la haute saison pour ces artistes ils
doivent jouer dans d'autres on est
obligés d'élargir nos activités et
devenir presque un tournant même si
c'est pas notre rôle
on sent diffuseur donc si c'est là notre
grande équipe de chaque année et aussi
des d'avoir des artistes qu'ils ont une
structure qui comprend tous les artistes
qu'on aimerait avoir qui sont très
connus sinon pas une structure
internationale
mais ces artistes là se rendront pas à
temps ce festival nous comprenez qu'on
pense assez important dans le choix des
artistes
mais quand on comprend on connaît pas
tout ce côté là bas c'est normal que les
gens puissent dire mais pourquoi lui
vient pas ces femmes voilà de l'actif
populaire on aurait tous le voir en
personne à montréal et il n'est pas là
où elle n'est pas là alors qui dit nuls
afrique dit aussi récit leurs prix
récompense est là cette année est ce que
vous avez des scoops en annoncée pour ce
qui est des
récompense des artistes qui vont être
primé depuis trois ans le créer le prix
nuits d'afrique pour la francophonie a
été créée dans le cadre du 30e
anniversaire de naissance et le premier
prier avec les données ne l'ont que manu
dibango c'est se donner à b j à des
artistes qui ont une grande renommée
internationale qui ont une vision très
rassembleur et qui représente la
francophonie dans toute cette diversité
culturelle à la francophonie s'est pas
seulement par les français bien sûr
hélas ici ce qu'on veut promouvoir donc
est donné ce prestige et de mon triste
ces artistes qui ont fait beaucoup à
travers leur carrière donc cette année
ça sera là ce sera sékouba bambino très
bien ça on est content d'avoir la
nouvelle en primeur à rci à 11 ans avec
des menus amitié très bien alors je sais
que vous êtes très occupé dont je peux
vous retenir indéfiniment
suzanne rousseau bon dans un monde idéal
que souhaitez vous pour votre festival
pour va dire pour pour les prochaines
années les allusions aux artistes qu'on
aimerait pouvoir diffuser partager
affirmait qu'elle vous souhaiteriez pour
votre festival
bon c'est un festival qui a quand même
32 ans qui contient qui a encore besoin
de grandir mode défi d'assumer cette
croissance et des souhaits de notre
président fondateur et de lui c'est que
le festival a duré 13 jours est la
position extérieure qui est maintenant
de 6 jours doit atteindre au moins tout
aussi longue que la durée du festival
aussi la superficie extérieur doit être
agrandi doit être agrandi
quand il y aura une rénovation n'ai rien
à se rendre jusqu'à la rue
sainte-catherine tout donné l'ampleur
qu'il médite est aussi
de pouvoir développer toutes les
activités connexes pas seulement les
grands spectacles à grand déploiement
sur la grande scène ça c'est quelque
chose qui est très important pour nous
mais aussi pour développer les activités
qui ont beaucoup de succès mais l'espace
est encore limitée pour nous les
activités pour la famille pour avoir
plus de diversité dans les annales du
deuxième set qui s'appelle quitte une
grande sphère qu'il ya des moments
intimes avec les artistes mais on en
programment pas assez parce qu'on n'a
pas l'espace
on doit pas faire des activités en même
temps donc c'est tout ça ces choses là
qu'on est en train de travailler pour
amener beaucoup plus et donner la lampe
lors que le nom mérite parce que le nom
on nous dit à l'international le
festival pour tout le monde c'est le
plus grand festival mais non travail
derrière pour lui donner l'espace encore
qui n'est pas encore arrivé
est ce que justement vous avez le
soutien de la ville de montréal et des
autorités au niveau provincial ou
fédéral pour ce festival la nuit par
tous les paliers gouvernementaux mais
n'est pas encore soutenu en tout cas on
vous le souhaite je suis à nouveau je
rappelle que vous êtes à directrice
générale du festival nuits d'afrique
merci beaucoup d'avenir temps de me
parler aujourd'hui
merci